Don't expect to hear this word
when you watch "Creed III."
Here's why Tessa Thompson absolutely
refused to say this word on camera.
Tessa Thomposon isn't pulling any punches
when it comes to shaping her "Creed III"
character. While Adonis Creed's journey on
the silver screen has largely been shaped by
the guidance and training he's received from
Rocky Balboa, it's important to note just how
important Bianca is to the boxing superstar.
A musician, Thompson's character was first
introduced in 2015's "Creed," where she served
as Adonis' love interest and emotional rock.
"Creed" wasn't just a one-off. A box
office juggernaut and Oscar nominee,
it went on to spawn a successful sequel
in 2018. Now, it's threequel time,
and Thompson's character is just as relevant
as she was on day one. With Bianca such a key
part of the "Creed" mythology, Thompson
has made it clear just how important it
is for her to shape Bianca. The actor said as
much in an exclusive interview with Looper,
where she opened up about being hands-on with
how the "Creed" character has evolved. She said,
"Something that feels exciting is
that I've always been invited to
be kind of a co-author and figure
that out with the collaborators."
While speaking with The Hollywood Reporter,
Tessa Thompson opened up about the importance
of maintaining Bianca's character arc throughout
the franchise. In "Creed III," Bianca and Adonis
are living the good life, enjoying their success
and fame. Because life is so cozy in Los Angeles,
a part of Bianca, namely her affinity for
Philadelphia, is less visible onscreen.
In the first "Creed," Bianca and Adonis first
begin to fall in love over cheesesteaks,
a Philadelphia staple. On their date,
Bianca explains to Adonis the meaning behind
"jawn," which has strong Philadelphia roots.
"So what's a jawn?"
"It's a noun. See, these is jawns, this is a jawn,
this restaurant that we're
in is a jawn, you're a jawn."
While the scene doesn't have the momentum or
high stakes of Adonis training or fighting,
it does allow Bianca and the boxer to bond,
eventually leading to their relationship,
which is at the heart of "Creed III."
Because "jawn" is so uniquely Philly, Thompson
refused to use it in the LA-focused "Creed III."
"I said to them, 'I'm not saying 'jawn'
in this movie because we've heard it,
we've done it. I want to break new territory.'
Not saying 'jawn' was also a way of saying
inside of the filmmaking that you are going to
witness someone that is constantly evolving."
Bianca's evolution from up-and-coming
musician to rockstar to talented producer
has been a powerful emotional arc of the
Creed trilogy, and subtly acknowledging
how far she's come from the Philly musician
we met in the first film is an interesting
and daring route for the character. And
Thompson doing her best to make Bianca
feel like a real person is nothing new for the
actress. In a 2015 interview with The Source,
Thompson revealed that she had never been to
Philadelphia prior to the first film's production.
"I never stepped foot in Philly
before I flew here to make the movie,
and I spent about two months
before shooting just getting
integrated and learning the dialect
and hanging out in the musical scene."
In a separate interview with The Hollywood
Reporter, Thompson opened up about how she
spent hours with Philly natives to learn
the vernacular that persisted throughout
the city. Years later, it's interesting to see
how invested Thompson is with the character,
to the point that she refuses to use a word
that's so synonymous with Philly culture now
that it's no longer applicable. As Bianca
becomes more attached to Los Angeles, is
it possible that she's becoming more personal to
Thompson, who was born in California metropolis?
With "Creed III," the future
of the franchise is open ended,
so here's hoping we get more of Bianca and
Creed as they tackle their next major battle.